.
A LOT TO TALK ABOUT.
>> LAURA: THIS IS INGRAM ANGLE
FROM WASHINGTON.
THE TWITTER FILES PART TWO.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
A FEW YEARS BACK CONSERVATIVES
STARTED NOTICING THAT THEIR
TWEETS WEREN'T GETTING THE
TRACTION THEY ONCE DID.
NOW, THE COMMON PARLANCE BECAME
KNOWN AS SHADOWBANNING, TO
SUPPRESS OR DE-AMPLY
IFY TH
VOICES OF CERTAIN PEOPLE.
>> ARE YOU CENSORING PEOPLE?
>> NO.
>> TWITTER SHADOWBANNING
DOMINANT REPUBLICANS, IS THAT
TRUE?
>> NO.
>> LAURA: HE WAS DOING
INTERMITTENT FASTING THEN --
TONIGHT JACK DORSEY BETTER BE
LAWYERING UP BECAUSE IT SURE
LOOKS LIKE HE LIED UNDER OATH.
PLAYING GAME OF SEMANTICS.
A LITTLE OVER TWO HOURS AGO,
FREE SPEECH CHAMPION BEA
WEI
SOME DROPS.
>> THE LABOR RAILS OF LAST
CENTURY, REMEMBER, THEY USED TO
CELLLISH IN THESE OLD STORIES
ABOUT HOW CONSERVATIVE
BLACKLISTED COMMUNIST
SYMPATHIZERS.
LOOK WHO IS DOING IT TONIGHT?
TONIGHT WE LEARNED BEFORE ELON,
THEY WOULD HAVE TEAMS OF TWITTER
EMPLOYEES BULL BLACKLISTS.
THEY WOULD PREVENT DISFAVORED
TWEETS FROM TRENDING AND
ACTIVELY LIMIT THE VISIBILITY OF
ENTIRE ACCOUNTS OR EVEN TRENDING
TOPICS ALL IN SECRET WITHOUT
INFORMING USERS.
TO THEIR BUSY BAN OF CENSORS,
THEY CALLED IT THE STRATEGIC
RESPONSE TEAM, THE GLOBAL
ESCALATION TEAM AND INCLUDED,
CHECK THIS OUT, THE HEAD OF
LEGAL POLICY AND, IRONICALLY
TRUST, THE GLOBAL HEAD OF TRUST
IN SAFETY, AND JACK DORSEY AND
OTHERS.
NOW, THERE WAS A CONCERTED
EFFORT THEN TO COVER IT ALL UP.
WRITING ON TWITTER'S OFFICIAL
BLOG IN JULY 2018, IT WAS
INSISTED THAT WE DO NOT SHADOW
BAN AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T
SHADOW BAN BASED ON POLITICAL
VIEWPOINTS OR IDEOLOGY.
OVER TIME THIS TWITTER EXECUTIVE
BECAME MORE INDIGNANT.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
WITH CENSORSHIP IS THE FACT YOU
PUSH PEOPLE UNDERGROUND AND YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING I WORRY
ABOUT.
>> LAURA: COME ON.
THE ONLY THING THAT KEPT THAT
WOMAN UP AT NIGHT WAS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT CONSERVATIVE
VOICES WOULD SOMEHOW SLIP
THROUGH THE CORPORATE CENSORS.
THE FIRST NAME MENTIONED ON THIS
TWITTER BLACKLIST RELEASED
TONIGHT WAS SOMEONE "THE ANGLE"
FIRST INTRODUCED TO THE NATIONAL
AUDIENCE DURING COVID.
STANFORD'S DR. JAY BHATTACHARYA.
HE AUTHORED WHAT CAME TO BE
KNOWN AS BARRINGTON DECLARATION.
THAT IT WAS DANGEROUS FOR OUR
KIDS.
>> IT DOES NOT COST LESS.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, PEOPLE
HAVE DELAYED CANCER TREATMENT,
THEY HAVE DELAYED GOING TO THE
DOCTOR BECAUSE, EVEN WITH SEVERE
HEART DISEASE, PARENTS HAVE NOT
VACCINATED THEIR CHILDREN.
THE LOCKDOWN COSTS, EVEN IN THE
SHORT INTERMEDIATE TERM HAVE
LARGER AND LONGER HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES.
>> LAURA: BOY, WAS HE RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO WEISS TWITTER
DEEMED HIS RESEARCH SO DANGEROUS
THAT IT SECRETLY PLACED HIM ON A
TRANSBLACKLIST WHICH PREVENTED
HIS TWEETS FROM TWEETING.
DR. BHATTACHARYA WILL JOIN US
EXCLUSIVELY IN A FEW MOMENTS.
REMEMBER, WE JUST LEARNED A FEW
WEEKS BACK THAT THIS WAS ALL
OCCURRING AT THE SAME TIME DR.
ANTHONY FAUCI'S DAUGHTER WORKED
AS AN ENGINEER AT TWITTER.
AND OTHER NAMES LISTED INCLUDE
PROMINENT CONSERVATIVES SUCH AS
CHARLIE KIRK AND DAN BONGINO.
SINCE THE ANGLE WAS PRETTY MUCH
THE FIRST NATIONAL PLATFORM TO
SLAM THE LOCKDOWNS I SUSPECT MY
OWN NAME WILL POP UP ON SOME
SUPPRESSION LIST EVENTUALLY.
I HOPE SO DURING THE SPRING OF
2020 I MYSELF NOTICED AND I
BELIEVE I SAID IT, THAT THE
REACH OF MY OWN TWEETS SEEMED TO
BE ODDLY DECLINING.
BUT FRANKLY, I THINK IT WAS
OBVIOUS TO ALL OF US AND ONE OF
THE MANY QUESTIONS LINGERING
TONIGHT IS WHETHER THERE WAS ANY
CONTACT BETWEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND TWITTER EXECUTIVES
THAT ENCOURAGED CENSORSHIP, OF
COURSE, FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
OF COURSE, WHEN ANY OF US
QUESTION BIG TECH'S MOTIVES OR
PRACTICES DURING THIS TIME,
WELL, WE WERE ALL TREATED LIKE
PARANOID CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
>> NOW WE REALIZE THAT IT WAS A
CANARD.
>> TALKS ABOUT CENSORSHIP AND
SHADOWBANNING WHICH THERE HAS
BEEN NO REAL PROOF OF.
>> LAURA: NO REAL PROOF OF?
THE ONLY THING HELD UP WAS
LEGITIMATE PUBLIC DEBATE AND
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE AND THERE IS
PLENTY OF EVIDENCE AND IT WAS
WORSE THAN JUST MERE
SUPPRESSION.
TOWARD THE END OF THE THREAD, IT
BECOMES CLEAR THAT SOME WITHIN
THE TWITTER LEADERSHIP DEVELOPED
SOMETHING LIKE A GOD COMPLEX.
IN EARLY 2021, IRONICALLY, THE
GLOBAL HEAD OF TRUST AND SAFETY,
THEN UNWITTINGLY FINGERED DORSEY
FOR APPROVING OF THE CENSORSHIP
AND EVEN USED THE WORD
"INTEGRITY" TO DESCRIBE WHAT
THEY WERE DOING.
WE GOT JACK ON-BOARD WITH
IMPLEMENTING THIS FOR CIVIC
INTEGRITY IN THE NEAR TERM BUT
WE'LL NEED TO MAKE A MORE ROBUST
CASE TO GET THIS INTO OUR
REPERTOIRE OF POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS, ESPECIALLY FOR
OTHER POLICY DOMAINS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
TWITTER'S MISSION ORIGINALLY WAS
TO GIVE EVERYONE THE POWER TO
CREATE AND SHARE IDEAS AND
INFORMATION INSTANTLY WITHOUT
BARRIERS.
WHAT WE SEE NOW WITHOUT A DOUBT,
THAT ALL OF THAT WAS JUST A
MARKETING CAMPAIGN.
BECAUSE BARRIERS WERE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THEIR STRATEGY
TO CONTROL AND DOMINATE THE
PUBLIC SQUARE.
NOW, IMAGINE, IF ELON MUSK HAD
NEVER BOUGHT TWITTER, WE WOULD
NEVER KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT ANY OF
THIS.
IT COST $44 BILLION, BUT NOW WE
SEE JUST HOW CORRUPT,